vamos a tomar una función s mayúscula de
t que lo que va a denotar es la posición
posición de un cierto objeto verdad pero
en función en función del tiempo del
tiempo tiempo entonces este es el tiempo
aquí voy a pintar la gráfica de la
función la voy a poner como una parábola
pero no necesariamente tiene que ser así
esto es nada más para darnos una mejor
idea y lo primero en lo que quiero
pensar es cómo sería el cambio en la
posición de un momento a de un momento a
otro momento ve va entonces aquí pongo
el momento b y para hacer esto lo que
tenemos que hacer es ver dónde estaba el
objeto en el momento a osea fijarnos en
esa idea porque esa idea es la posición
al tiempo y luego vamos a ver a dónde
llegó aquí llega a ese debe a ese debe y
esa de ahí es la posición en el tiempo
ve así para encontrar el cambio de a ave
el cambio en posición tenemos que hacer
la diferencia de estos dos valores hay
que considerar a ese debe menos sda
dejame escribir eso por aquí en algún
lugar entonces el cambio
el cambio en posición no imposición
de a
es el spp es ese debe sdb - s d s d a
hasta ahorita no he hecho nada demasiado
impresionante ahora vamos a estudiar la
derivada para ver qué más podemos decir
entonces la derivada de s como la
pensamos pues la podemos pensar como la
pendiente de en cada punto verdad por
ejemplo en este punto la pendiente
quedaría más o menos como algo así y la
forma en la cual pensamos está pendiente
de manera algebraica es que nos fijamos
cuál es el cambio en la posición y eso
lo dividimos entre el cambio en el
tiempo y todo es así de manera
infinitesimal aquí super chiquito
entonces pues fijándonos en ese
coeficiente nos quedaría el cambio de
posición dividido entre el cambio de
tiempo un cambio instantáneo bueno
también existe la anotación con prima
verdad entonces déjame escribirlo así lo
voy a poner como que s prima de t
y esto tiene la ventaja de indicarnos
que también es una función del tiempo va
en cada en cada momento tenemos un pues
una derivada distinta pero ahorita como
estamos hablando de la posición que
sería este cambio instantáneo pues esto
justo sería la velocidad la velocidad
una velocidad en función del tiempo en
función
función del tiempo bien muy bien bueno
como es algo importante como es una
función que se llama velocidad pues
vamos a ponerle nombre vamos a llamarle
vedette y también vamos a hacer su
gráfica va entonces aquí voy a pintar
otros ejes fíjate que están alineados
para que veamos cómo queda y vamos a
graficar la velocidad al principio la
pendiente 0 entonces empezamos en este
punto de por acá pero luego la pendiente
va creciendo si esto de adeveras es una
parábola aquí va creciendo linealmente y
llega digamos a este punto de por acá
aquí la pendiente ya es muy alta así que
la gráfica la gráfica de la velocidad se
vería como una línea así déjamelo indicó
esto de aquí es la gráfica de ye igual a
bt y la de acá arriba es la gráfica de
che igual a
s mayúscula de té excelente ahora
queremos ver cómo se relaciona pues esta
función velocidad con el cambio en
posición de a a b desde a hasta b
entonces déjame marcar por aquí a aquí a
la misma altura aquí está a ahora que
esta vez y para pensar en este cambio en
posición de aaa b lo que vamos a hacer
es utilizar una suma de riman y recuerda
las sumas de riman pues se involucran
figuras geométricas ahorita lo vamos a
hacer con rectángulos entonces voy a
pintar aquí tres rectángulos a le voy a
dibujar esta región en tres rectángulos
ahorita los voy a poner un poco gruesos
pero en realidad este puedes pensar que
son muchísimos los que estoy poniendo
así para tener más espacio para escribir
entonces van a ser rectángulos con el
mismo largo y suelto perdón y su altura
va a estar dada por la función evaluada
en el extremo izquierdo bueno entonces
esto de acá que hace o sea si tomamos la
suma de las áreas de estos rectángulos
que que nos da pues pues por un lado
sabemos que eso es la aproximación del
área por debajo de la función pero vamos
a ver si podemos decir que otra cosa la
verdad realidad es una aproximación un
poco burda pero vamos a ver como más o
sea de que de qué otra forma se puede
interpretar bueno vamos con el primer
rectángulo que lo voy a pintar así de
color naranja
cuál sería el área de este primer
rectángulo pues bueno su altura es es v
esta es la función ve evalúa de nada
entonces sería de de a y eso hay que
multiplicarlo por la base que vamos a
ponerle delta de t un pequeño cambio
ente que es un cambio bueno que ese
cambio es igual para todos los
rectángulos pero esto qué quiere decir
ya interpretándolo en posición y
velocidad
pues mira la velocidad le estamos
multiplicando por un periodo de tiempo
entonces esto sería una aproximación
para el cambio de posición en este
intervalo
si la velocidad va cambiando pero aquí
lo estamos haciendo con una velocidad
fija entonces es nada más una
aproximación de manera similar el
segundo rectángulo pues ahora tiene
altura bueno no sé muy bien creo que
aquí es además más del tate pero el
chiste es que el área de este segundo
rectángulo una vez más nos va a dar una
aproximación del cambio de posición en
este intervalo y también pasa lo mismo
con éste con el moralito va
con el morado entonces vamos a poner
todo esto en términos de la anotación de
la anotación esta que estábamos usando
la anotación sigma entonces en general
en general estos rectángulos tienen área
bueno área acumulada la suma desde y
igual a 1 hasta n de aquí tengo que
poner la función que en este caso es b b
le voy a poner dt y menos 1 va o sea los
valores los vamos cambiando acá x delta
t ok entonces estoy acá es una
aproximación pues por un lado para el
área que queda por debajo de la gráfica
de la función pero por lo que platicamos
término a término esto de acá también es
una aproximación para el cambio de la
posición y para el cambio de la posición
de la ave déjame escribirlo nada más
antes aquí éste es del tate hay que
acordarnos que
voy a poner por acá dónde
del tate este delta te lo podemos
encontrar como ve - a entre 12 horas y
regresando a lo que decía estoy acá es
una aproximación para dos cosas es una
aproximación voy a poner así
aproximación número uno para el cambio
de posición
cambio de posición posición
posición y número 2 para el área bajo la
curva área
bajo la
entonces espero que con esto más o menos
vayas agarrando una intuición de que por
lo tanto el área por debajo de la curva
de velocidad va a ser igual al cambio de
posición ya nada más vamos mejorando y
mejorando nuestras aproximaciones vamos
a hacer eso como lo haríamos para
obtener el valor exacto del área por
debajo de esta curva pues lo que dice
riman es que tomemos el límite y el
límite de cuando n tiende a infinito de
esta aproximación de acá si tomamos ese
límite tenemos una infinidad de
rectángulos y por lo tanto ahí sí
tendríamos si tendríamos el área que
queda por debajo de la curva eso sería
igual sería igual a la integral de a a b
d b
dt
de té de japonés hace un poco más bonita
btt de té vale entonces ahora si esto de
aquí ya nos da el área exacta por debajo
de la curva pero igual nos da el cambio
de posición exacto si estoy acá también
es igual ya así déjame bajar un poquito
esto es igual lo voy a poner con color
pues con color amarillo estoy acá es el
cambio de posición exacto cambio de
posición
exacto exacto de ave
ya sabe pero mira este cambio de
posición exacto de a ave lo habíamos
calculado lo habíamos calculado acá
arriba de otra forma como se debe
- esa idea entonces esta integral es
igual a esta integral es igual a ese
bebé menos sda dejame lo escribo voy a
poner así sdb menos sda esa idea y esta
igualdad está súper interesante en damas
déjame reescribir la porque es
importante entonces lo que nos dice es
que la integral la integral de a ave dvd
dvd t de t es igual a s debe es
mayúscula de b - sd a a esto está
padrísimo va este resultado aunque
ahorita está un poco esté oculto porque
estoy usando velocidad y posiciones en
el fondo es un resultado súper conocido
y es el segundo teorema fundamental
teorema fundamental del cálculo
del cálculo
a lo mejor te estás preguntando dónde
está el primero si no hemos platicado de
eso bueno ya lo dejaremos para después
pero ahorita este resultado es súper
útil para evaluar integrales definidas
integrales en donde conocemos los
extremos y por lo tanto para evaluar el
área debajo de una curva va porque está
tan padre ya nada más déjame
reescribirlo así en general o sea porque
imagínate que llegas y te piden
encontrar la integral de a a b de una
cierta función f
dt para entonces nos piden encontrar
esto de acá en el dibujito que sería en
el dibujito sería tienes ahí los ejes
tienes por acá la gráfica de la función
f y lo que piden es encontrar el área
por debajo de la gráfica que queda entre
a y b entonces nos piden encontrar eso
bueno pues lo que dice el segundo
teorema fundamental del cálculo es que
basta encontrar
efe efe mayúscula 1
anti derivada
andy derivada
de f minúscula entonces tomamos f
mayúscula una anti derivada de efe
minúscula es lo que pasa acá arriba
verdad acá arriba tenemos que s es
mayúscula es anti derivada
anti derivada
dv entonces tomamos esa anti derivada de
f y para evaluar la integral únicamente
hay que evaluar esa anti derivada en el
extremo superior y aquí sería en b ya
eso tenemos que restar la anti derivada
y evaluada en a esto está fantástico con
esto podemos evaluar integrales
definidas y por lo tanto podemos
encontrar áreas por debajo de una curva
bueno espero que le hayas agarrado la
onda a este concepto es súper útil en
los siguientes vídeos vamos a ver
algunos ejemplos de cómo se aplica